yeah vegas jam cafe lola is expanding
their instagramable and delicious empire
rocky stopped by their new location to
learn more about their story and
interior inspo take a look
so the saying is it was always lola here
at cafe lola's newest location they're
fourth in the southwest area now
alexandra before we get into the
interiors and the five here i have to
know i'm sure a lot of people want to
know who is lola here's our actually
number one asked question okay
so let me know that people want to know
so lola actually was my dog i had her
for 13 years she's a cavalier king
charles i she was like the love of my
life before i had kids and lynn's mom my
business partner her mom's name was lola
so when we met we're like it was meant
to be we are we already knew the name
before we even had the coffee shop oh my
gosh it's pure alignment i love that and
you're celebrating your lola so
beautifully yeah thank you so let's talk
about your partnership with lynn because
you guys are the stars of this gorgeous
portrait by the way so how did that come
together so my husband actually
introduced us and then we started
working together pretty like right away
and we started working out of coffee
shops and we just noticed that a lot of
them were like masculine kind of darker
browns yeah they didn't have a lot of
options i'm actually gluten-free so a
lot of times they didn't have
gluten-free pastries or things i could
eat so when we um noticed there was a
big gap in the market we just wanted to
create a feminine coffee shop that was
pink it had a lot of flowers
instagramable exactly but not only the
aesthetic was important to us we wanted
to make sure that food was excellent and
then we had really good quality drinks
so
absolutely well
you guys have a huge following on tick
tock instagram everyone loves the food
and the drinks but they also are coming
in for the interior so can you just
explain how this location is different
from your others yeah so this location
we made it a little bit more modern all
of our little all of our locations are a
little bit different with the different
neon signs and then this one we have to
las vegas yeah
we have this one was created by lola the
artist and um lola sanchez is her name
the artist is her name is lola
crazy more alignment here and we wanted
we wanted actually this is the only
location that has blues we wanted to
bring in a little bit more rainbow since
we're on the rainbow yeah so we were
like we thought it was kind of cool yeah
and yeah so she created
um a really cool portrait of us and we
just thought everyone could come in and
feel inspired and just be connected to
lola absolutely and i love that this is
a family friend affair here at all your
lolita locations sophie would you mind
showing us a little sneak peek of the
kids menu show how to do it what's she
gonna make what's going to make so this
is our under the sea lemonade it's
actually our most popular kids drink and
it's a little bit of magic in there can
you give it a close-up on the magic look
at that show let's see it
let's see the
magic i didn't pour it in
oh wow wow
that is so fun
and that's fun for kids and adults okay
it's actually super delicious okay
sophie do you mind if i try it
can you try it no it's yours okay i'll
try it later on in the show okay we're
gonna talk more about the menu and
what's on the kids menu and the menu for
everyone right yes all right i'll send
it back to you guys